it's always been brash and controversial
but is big brother really a part of
britain's cultural heritage
the national trust thinks it is and it's
opening the house to the public
big brother struck me very strongly as
something which had really aroused
passions which perhaps was a little
controversial but which was nonetheless
very much part of our extraordinarily in
a way part of our national history who
is she who is she where did you find her
now look you've still got cream all over
your whiskers
my name is shilpa
jackie get that right i don't understand
your life
you don't need to understand
the reality show has turned ordinary
people into celebrities and generated
countless tabloid headlines
yes
all 500 tickets for this weekend were
sold within one hour
the paying public will be able to come
here to the big brother diary room and
sit in the famous chair though let's be
honest it's not the kind of furniture
you'd expect to see
in a national trust property now
traditionalists may question whether
this is really a great idea mixing
celebrity culture with national trust
but those behind the tv show say in
terms of getting young people on board
big brother is the perfect vehicle
i think it is totally part of british
culture and british heritage um
everybody knows what big brother is in
this country whether you watch it or not
if you like it or not everybody knows
about it and everybody has a vague idea
what's going on the big brother house
and i think that that says it all
for some people however this is the kind
of house that should be getting all the
attention i'm a member of the national
trust i'm not going to be burning my
membership card in the streets and
taking to the barricades but i do think
this is a somewhat ill-chosen venture
i do understand the trust's view that
they want to appeal to a slightly more
modern audience that they don't just
want old folk traipsing around stately
homes all the time they want some
something fresh for those who have a
ticket this is a chance to see a
property that very few people ever get
inside and the brady sky news in the big
brother house